We're now going to introduce
the concept of potential energy.
Let's begin by
considering a system where
a conservative force is acting.
So I'll consider a conservative
force, which I'll call F sub c.
So force set to force, the work
integral is path independent.
So the work integral for this
force is the integral of F sub
c .ds, which is the path
going from point A to point B.
And for a conservative force,
this integral does not depend
upon the path from A to B.
It's independent of A and B.
So it depends only
upon the endpoints.
So this is a path
independent integral.
And since it depends
only upon the endpoints,
I can write it, since it's going
to be an integral from point A
to point B-- this
integral must be
equal to some function
of the final point.
So some function of r
sub B minus some function
of the initial point r sub A.
And to just get this integral
from A to B, in our usual way of
evaluating a definite integral,
it's going to be equal
to some function of r
B minus some function of r A,
since the integral depends only
upon the endpoints.
Now, let's call
this function-- I'm
going to make a sort of
funny choice here-- so let's
call this function minus U as a
function of position factor r.
And we'll see the reason for
this funny choice of minus sign
in just a moment.
So now with this definition,
my work integral, which again,
is the integral of F sub c .ds
from point A to point B is now
minus U of r B minus minus
U of r A. So in other words,
that's minus U of r B-- so minus
minus gives me a plus U of r
sub A.
For shorthand, I can write that
as minus U sub B plus U sub A.
And since we start out at
point A and go to point B,
notice that I can
also write this
as the negative of the change
in U. Since the final value of U
is r U at B and the
initial value is U at A,
so this minus U B plus U
A is equal to minus delta
U, the change in U as
we go from the initial
to the final position.
And note that in addition
to that, given that this
is the work integral,
I can summarize that
by writing that--
so I'll say, note
that delta U is equal to the
negative of the work done
going from point
A to point B. Now,
let's write the work kinetic
energy theorem using this newly
introduced U function.
So the work kinetic
energy theorem,
which tells us that the
work done, which we've seen
is minus U sub B plus U sub
A is equal to the change
in kinetic energy delta k, which
I can write as K sub B minus K
sub A. Or I could also write
that as 1/2 M V B squared
minus 1/2 M V A squared.
So this is just me stating that
the work done on the system
is equal to the change
in kinetic energy.
And I can write the work
in terms of my function U
that I've introduced here to
minus U sub B plus U sub A.
So I'm going to rearrange
this equation now--
basically the one involving
U's and the one involving
kinetic energies-- so that I
have all the terms involving
point A on one side and
all the terms involving
point B on the other side.
So rearranging, I get
that at point A 1/2 M V
A squared plus U sub A is equal
to at point B 1/2 M V B squared
plus U sub B. Now,
notice however,
that there is nothing
special about how
I chose the points A and B.
They're completely arbitrary.
So that means that
this equation must
be true for any points A and B.
And what that means
is that each side
must be equal to
the same constant
for any point in the system.
So in fact, we can write
that K plus U for any point
must be able to
some constant, which
I'm going to call E sub mech.
So K here is the kinetic energy.
U is my function
that I introduced,
and we're going to call
it the potential energy.
And E sub mech-- and
remember, this E sub mech
here is a constant.
E sub mech is
something that we call
the total mechanical energy.
Now, what we've done
here is that we've
shown that the total
mechanical energy, which
is the sum of the kinetic
energy and the potential energy,
is a constant under the action
of a conservative force.
In other words, if we
look at this equation
and look at how it
changes with time,
the change in the kinetic
energy, plus the change
in the potential energy
is equal to the change
in the total mechanical energy.
And this is 0 for our
conservative force.
So in other words, the
change in kinetic energy
is balanced by the change
in potential energy, such
that the sum is 0 when the
force acting is conservative.
Now, we've now introduced
the very important concept
of the potential energy
that is associated
with the conservative force.
And we see that the change
in the potential energy,
the way we defined it, the
change in potential energy
is equal to the negative
of the work integral
for our conservative
force going from point A
to point B. Now in
fact, it's actually
only the change in
the potential energy
that has physical significance.
We'll be concerned with
potential energy differences
or changes.
The actual value of
the potential energy
itself doesn't matter.
We're free to choose
any convenient reference
point, or 0 point, for
measuring the potential energy.
It's equivalent to choosing
a coordinate origin when
we're talking about positions.
Now, the potential
energy change is
related to the work done
by conservative forces.
But we know that
in general, work
can also be done by
non-conservative forces.
Although, that work by
non-conservative forces
will depend upon the path
taken from point A to point B.
So in general, the
total work is given
by the sum of the
conservative work--
the work done by
conservative forces, which
we can relate to a
potential energy change,
and the non-conservative
work done.
And it's this total
work that tells us
what the change in
the kinetic energy is.
Now we'll soon see
that in the presence
of non-conservative forces, the
total mechanical energy, which
is K plus U, is not a constant.